he's calling in from Dodgers camp today
how are you Tom Verducci I am well I'm
actually watching clayton kershaw
throwing live BP to yasiel puig here's a
tip for you rich disservice Kershaw a
guy yes now that's the sort of stuff
that we want in a Honda inside a report
from you sir and I appreciate you you
calling in and giving us those two cents
all right I don't know what I'm more
surprised by the accounting the non
pitching change mounds visits or after
all this talk of the pitch clock it's
not going to be implemented this season
what's the scoop on that one Tom yeah
all the talk about the pitch clock and
the Commissioner acting tough he's gonna
implement pace of play rules to me this
was a big nothing burger you know the
six mound visits the average last year
was eight and don't forget there are
certain provisions in years and allow
teams to go beyond six if there's a
pinch hitter you can go out again if
you're cross upon signs you can go out
again so where's the game I mean the
biggest problem in today's game is the
dawdling that goes on between pitches
and that's got up almost three seconds
in a decade which adds up to thirteen
minutes of pure dead time in between
pitches what's being done about that
next to nothing so I think when you're
watching a game of 2018 it's going to
look a lot like 2017 with I think it's a
distraction now to be keeping track of
these mound visits like what what is a
mouth is the first baseman goes three
quarters of the way to the mound to talk
to the pitcher about bunt defense at a
mountain visit well the other team be
screaming hey at the mound visit I yeah
I listen any little bit helps but it's
not gonna make a dent in the problem I
mean just after Joe Girardi's no longer
the manager of the Yankees Tom I mean
this is debts then you know those are
the mound visits that I think they're
trying to eliminate is Sanchez coming
out every two seconds to try and talk to
the pitcher or encouraged to do that
that that I guess is what they're trying
to get out of the game right Tom yes yes
Sanchez comes to by Wilson Contreras
Cubs come to mind
these guys are continually going out to
the
most cases it's because they need to
change the sign but a lot of times the
signs get very complicated and they need
to verbally confirm with the picture
that they're on the same page so it will
make a difference they're already
talking with some clubs about they're
gonna have to go to more hand signals to
say hey we're going to go to the second
set of signs here and yet that will make
a difference those catchers like Sanchez
and Contreras they're they're gonna have
to adjust their game with this limit
yeah because I assume these are the ones
who are gonna be fined right players who
consistently are flagrantly violate the
time limits will be subject to
progressive discipline for just cause by
the office of the commissioner reading
right yes that means I mean what kind of
fines are we talking about you know
remember in 2015 they had that rule
where the hitter has to keep two feet in
the batter's box and for the first
couple of months they started sending
out warning letters and then they
started finding people there were
actually some hitters who said figure
out how many at-bats I'm going to get
figure out what the spine is multiply
that I'll pay in advance because the
spine really is not going to bother a
lot of these guys they figured out that
finding people does not really change
behavior so I'd like to know what these
fines are going to be how aggressive
they're going to be implementing them
there's baseball need to be fixed - well
it doesn't need to be fixed because it's
not broken anymore people consume
baseball in more ways than ever before
the last two postseasons have been
unbelievable there's a lot of momentum
young stars I mean other sports would
kill for so many young stars in the game
that baseball has right now I think it
just needs to adapt rich to a coming
generation of fans who have so many
diversions to pick from that when the
game slows down their attention their
eyeballs are easily geared towards
something else
and I think that's what basically I call
it modernizing or updating think of it
as an update to your software just
updating the games that the game just
moves quicker but no it doesn't need to
be fixed Tom Verducci joining me here on
the Rich Eisen show what is the hospital
signing mean to you
I like that sign it reminds me a little
bit
when the Nationals stepped up and got
jayson werth before they were good but
they could see good coming where it made
sense Hosmer is a guy I think when you
give him that money he's not going to
change this guy's a baseball rat loves
the game is an influencer in the
clubhouse bilingual guy he has a lot of
impact a lot of different players great
work ethic so yeah I think it's this -
what what San Diego wants to do their
farm system is loaded right now when
this team gets good he's going to be a
part of it so I like this deal I really
do and I think last year the year he had
last year with a little more power shows
you that you may get more power out of
Hosmer than what we say in the past and
his JD Martinez enough for the Red Sox
it was mandatory I thought it was really
necessary for the team to go out and buy
power and I didn't think there was a
fallback position and I think for JD
maybe Arizona on a short term deal I
just couldn't see them going to the
dollars Boston could have so to me he
had one place to go and the Red Sox had
one bat to go get and it was marriage we
waited for months to happen but I think
it had to happen so yeah it's a really
good signing for them I still like the
Yankees if the Yankees are absolutely
loaded especially with depth besides you
know too big power hitters it's gonna be
tough for Boston to run down New York
Tom Verducci joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show so which wits JD Martinez our
drew when it's all said and done is
gonna have a bigger impact on the
history of the Boston Red Sox Tom what
do you think you know I think JD's like
a lot of guys cuz the Boston you need to
get off to a good start and what I'm
concerned about is his power is mostly
all to right-field
he's not a right-handed pole hitter
who's gonna be pounding balls over the
wall or off the wall hitting the ball
the other way as a right-handed hitter
in Fenway early in the season
that's a tough draw you know the ball
doesn't carry it's a lot more after
those bullpen you know his strengths it
doesn't play to the ballpark and like
New York like Philadelphia Boston man
that first impression is you
yes get off on a good foot there so I'd
like to say red Saxon has need a little
patience with j-b early in the season
but that's not their strong suit what's
the talk in Dodger camp Tom I mean what
is a team that came oh so close and has
immense expectations about it what do
they talk about on February 20th they
know they're good enough to win the
World Series now it's you know getting
so close similar to what Kansas City had
in 14 it's a motivating factor they know
how to get there and he just know how to
have to find a way to finish it it's
again extremely deep rich I mean we we
think about Dodgers you start with
Kershaw you say well they kind of mix
and match with their rotation but that's
what they do they have so many options
in the bullpen so many options in the
rotation that you know you're not going
to see anybody else Kershaw pitch 180
innings that works for them they're
incredibly crowded in the outfield good
old boyfriend Matt Kemp is back how
about that Matt can't believe Roger
uniform I believe might actually make
this team but in a crowded roster I'll
tell ya there's there's established big
leaders everywhere in this camp and yet
Houston still a favorite to repeat what
do you think I think so I mean listen
throughout the fact that this is now the
longest period in World Series history
without a repeat champion I come back to
the Yankee teams and just that alone
tells you it's hard to do in this day
and age but if you didn't know that and
you just looked at rosters you got to go
with Houston I'm sorry I mean that that
rotation is terrific and deep the one
rotation it's going to give you a lot of
innings and all sensibly I think the
best baseball top to bottom so I love
their managers I love their manager to
Tom I think if there's anybody that
knows he's probably studying about 15
different ways to mentally prepare them
or going through people who have done it
before AJ Hinch is going to be as ready
as any of those guys on that team to I
would agree with that rich I mean he's
sort of like the temple of what you
wanted a modern manager today but I know
I'll rewind the clock to twelve months
being Cubs camp last year and they got
Joe man Theo Epstein Jed holier they're
saying all the right things about
staying off of that slow start that will
champions coming back to try to repeat
space and they still got to be all-star
break two games under 500 it's just
human nature they did everything they
could from you know kind of slow playing
their starting pitchers and spring
training to sing on top of them about
being focused and they still got out of
blocks low so sometimes human nature is
your biggest enemy when it comes to
repeating well Tom unfortunately I've
reached my question count as the
Commissioner's Office told me I had only
ten questions for you so unfortunately
in turn you got to build up your
question frame that's true that's true
take care of Tom's great chat and as
always thank you got it again live
spring training game schedule begins on
MLB Network Friday featuring the
Nationals a me aforementioned Astros at
1:00 eastern time go ahead and visit MLB
network.com for both schedules and that
was the Honda inside a reporter Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience